c'était une mesure très injuste
considéré que la solidarité doit se
faire entre les retraités et les actifs
d'autant que les actifs vont avoir une
compensation par la baisse des
cotisations sociales donc une
augmentation du net sur la feuille de
salaire mais les retraités eux ne sont
pas bénéficiaires d'une mesure identique
donc la
l'augmentation de la csg pour les
retraités c'est une perte sèche de
revenus aux deux pour ceux qui sont au
dessus de 1200 euros
je considère pour ma part que 6200 euros
du fait de la moyenne des retraites peut
être considérée comme une retraite plus
tôt plus élevé que la moyenne
oui mais comme moyen de vivre et comme
capacité de pouvoir d'achat ça reste
faible 1200 euros donc c'est une mesure
injuste d'autant que les pointes de
répartition des richesses en france et
dans le monde ne sont pas entre les
actifs et ceux qui ont été actifs avant
eux
c'est entre ceux qui profitent à fond de
la mondialisation la financiarisation de
l'économie et ceux là ont par ailleurs
était bien servi par le gouvernement
avec à la fois la diminuer la
modification de dsf qui devient
maintenant un impôt exclusivement sur le
patrimoine immobilier et n'est plus un
impôt sur les actifs financiers en
particulier où la flat tax
donc c'est très injuste la part du
gouvernement de vouloir faire financer
par les retraités ou par les familles on
en parlera peut-être tout à l'heure avec
la diminution de la page
les énormes cadeaux fiscaux qui sont
faits à 10% de la population